and Sarah Carter has also obtained notes
from Bruce or and according to her
reporting in one of wars notes from May
2017 he writes about a call with
Christopher Steele and reveals that
Steele was quote very concerned about
commis firing afraid they will be
exposed joining us now with more is Fox
News contributor Sarah Carter the New
York Times bestselling author of the
Russia hoax the allistic schemed to
clear Hillary and framed Donald Fox News
legal analyst Greg jarred and Florida
congressman Matt gates all right good
evening everyone now Sarah what you have
unearthed some additional information
why don't you tell us what that is well
I think it's very telling of what Bruce
or in his relationship with Christopher
steel and how concerned Christopher
steel was that they would be exposed
there was also another text message
judge Jeanine that I was able to that I
was able to publish last week and it was
about the firewalls and Christopher
steel basically asks Bruce or will our
firewalls that we have in place hold
will these firewalls hold and this is
also very telling and something that is
very concerning to Congress because
apparently it seems that they
premeditated and worked around use Bruce
or is a back-channel to deliver Steele's
messages straight over to the FBI even
though he had been fired but they put up
firewalls and what Congress wants to
know is who were these and what were
these firewalls and that's what they'll
be asking him on August 28th when they
bring him in for deposition all right
and Matt Gaetz I mean you certainly had
your share of inquiries of these
individuals when he does come before I
believe two committees at the end of
August I mean what do you expect to hear
now either we're hearing things that he
didn't talk about in the past we know
that Bruce and Nellie or are the Bonnie
and Clyde of collusion think about what
we just learned a foreign spy is upset
that he's not able to use our own
Justice Department enough to poison an
influence
Robert Muller's investigation this is
after fusion GPS hired the spouse of
Bruce or two
be able to have their influence you have
the spouse of a senior Justice
Department official colluding with an
agent of a foreign government
Christopher Steele with the express
purpose of trying to destabilize a u.s.
presidential election why is this not
what we're looking at two wives Robert
Moll are not looking into this foreign
interference and not the hoax of the
Trump Russia investigation that by the
way Gregg Jarrett points out beautifully
in his new book that's such a nice plug
Sarah let me ask you something when the
congressman talked about the fact that
Nellie was hired by fusion Nellie or do
we know when she was hired by fusion GPS
yeah she was hired by fusion GPS in 2016
for the election that's right with the
very specific purpose a judge Jeanine to
actually investigate the Trump Russia
issue the dossier remember she's fluent
in Russian she's also a Russia expert
this was very well coordinated and I
agree with Matt Gaetz 100% congressman
Gates is right this was an effort to
bring Russian disinformation in this
dossier into our election and to affect
the election right and Gregg Jarrett I
mean you know what Bruce or it looks to
me is is in legal jeopardy what could he
be charged I mean these are the
documents 63 pages I've looked through
them over the last 10 days that I've had
them and it's clear to me that he is in
legal jeopardy it's astonishing that
he's still employed and here's why
Bruce Anneli Wars bank account is
getting fatter and fatter because of the
dossier that they are both peddling he
doesn't disclose it under federal
regulations he's required to do so so
that is potentially a crime filing a
false report right but beyond that using
your federal office for personal
financial gain is federal gratuity
statute violation bribery statute
violation honest services violate these
guys know this in the Department of
Justice why is the guy still working
because the Department of
justice is run by a feckless Attorney
General named Jeff Sessions and rod
Rosenstein the Deputy Attorney General
who is obstructing Congress I believe to
cover up his own participation and
wrongdoing he filed and signed the
renewal application for the wiretap on
the Trump campaign without the required
evidence right and I wanted to make a
point about what what Greg just said rod
Rosenstein won't tell us when he first
learned that Nelly or was working for
fusion GPS so I want to know from Bruce
or when did he tell his colleagues at
the Department of Justice that in
violation of the law that required him
to disclose his wife's occupation and
her sources of income he did not do that
and so when did all the other people at
the Department of Justice find this out
because rod Rosenstein I've asked him
twice in the open hearing and he will
not give an answer I think there's a
real smoking gun there yeah I think
there's more than this smoking gun there
but but let's go back Sarah Carter to
the whole idea of Nelly or getting the
job right before the election and then
as Greg says you know pocketing all of
this cash and their bank account and and
or is facilitating trying to get
Christopher Steele has been cut loose
down the Muller team now why are they so
invested in this that they know that
they can be charged with crimes lose
their job what is it that they're so
caught up on they're caught up on
removing President Trump they're caught
up on pushing this disinformation these
lies into the American public and into
the media and trying to get these lies
to stick and what they didn't expect
what they didn't expect was for all of
this to come out and be revealed judge
Jeanine and now we look at rod Rosen
Stein and let me just say one thing
about this he signed that fourth FISA
application he would have known he would
have known all of this information
because remember there were four
renewals so he should have known what
was in there and if he did it then
there's something wrong with him because
this is one of the
biggest cases in the country well I want
to talk about the Manafort trial today
guys we're now in the second day and
Greg I'm going to start with you
deliberations and the the jury has been
let go for the evening when I was a
judge I very often would keep juries
once they got a case I would keep them
in especially in a case like this where
there is so much public interest but
what do you think it seems that the
defense attorney is very heartened by
some of the questions about reasonable
doubt that's right they sent out a
question yesterday to the judge what's
the definition of reasonable doubt as
you know the former judge in the DA
there is no legal standard definition
for reasonable doubt because we leave it
to the discretion and determination of
the jurors themselves it's a very very
high burden and the reason the defense
is pleased about that is because they
mounted a reasonable doubt defense they
didn't call a case in earnest but they
did it through cross-examination what do
you think is gonna happen well I think I
think that they have tried to zero in or
on one or two jurors to either hang the
jury or convince the jury unanimously
there is reasonable doubt you cannot
convict you know congressman what do you
think it's gonna happen in this case
well I think it's gonna be overblown
because nothing in this case has
anything to do with Donald Trump the
Trump campaign 2016 convicted IIIi don't
know I guess I just don't really care if
Paul Manafort pay his taxes in the 80s
or 90s like you know to the same extent
that CNN seems to follow it every single
second I just don't think that it's it
has any relevance and it's distracting
the country it should have been an IRS
audit and a civil penalty plus interest
and yeah this is what's due Greg gets
what they do Sarah you got ten seconds
okay but we see what happened today
which i jealous coming out and saying
that he has been threatened that he has
to have you know the security of
marshals and now there's a lot of
concern about these jurors
this is what happens judge Jeanine when
we have this such a divisive country
right now and so much rhetoric from the
other side I'm surprised that he has let
them out
so that there's a possibility of
tampering this is a very very hot
climate guys anyway thank you all for
being here tonight appreciate your input